just another great season on fox sports
for uh for he and gus and the rest of
that crew
just again those shots of the ohio state
michigan game of both teams coming out
of the tunnel with the snow falling
right
i mean that was amazing
amazing and then he um he and gus called
the uh big ten championship game this
weekend and he's joining us right now i
believe from the uh the hall of fame
ceremonies that are going down in las
vegas nevada involving college football
joe klatt joining us here from fox
sports back on the rich eisen show how
are you doing joel
good bud how are you i'm better for
talking to you i'm seriously mad i mean
like going into the michigan ohio state
game you know i was nervous as a cat and
and so i didn't want to be part of any
of the hype and the pre-game stuff i
flipped the game on like 10 minutes
before and
and they're showing both teams coming
out of the tunnel snow coming down i'm
thinking to myself
you know with all due respect to sec and
pac-12 and other parts of this great
football-loving nation that's what
football is that's college football
right there
it was right i mean so good that was
that i mean the energy was amazing in
the building i mean that's i think an
obvious but then just the
the scene it was epic it was you know i
was down on the field before the game
right and and i'm standing with a few of
the guys
and
and the snow starts to just like come
down softly and we're all sitting there
and we're just like this is perfect this
is perfect this is the perfect scene now
i don't think that the ohio state fans
thought that because they got a
pass-oriented offense so it's certainly
lending itself towards you know favoring
michigan with the some of that moisture
coming down but having said that man the
scene in the atmosphere was second to
none so do you think the college
football playoff committee got it right
joel
what do you think well they got the best
four teams um which is what they're
charged to do
um
as long as they they didn't
i i think as long as they didn't factor
in a potential rematch
with bama and georgia in the semifinal
then then you can't argue with what they
did
alabama's resume is really good
michigan's resume is really good
and and i think that you know
both of those teams would have been
deserving number one teams
the
the appearance that there was
and avoid an avoiding of this semi-final
of georgia alabama i i don't love that
now they said that that didn't take
place so i don't want to knock them for
something that they're they're claiming
didn't take place but having said that i
actually think it would have been better
to rematch them and just say like listen
we're not going to allow you access to a
national championship
you know just because
we think you're good georgia and you're
better than cincinnati because you
didn't win an a a conference
championship that's always been my
problem with this model and it's not
going to be fixed anytime soon maybe an
expansion we can do some things with the
language that honor and and
incentivize the conference championship
but until that happens this is kind of
what you're going to get and it's
certainly not something that michigan
fans wanted to see you didn't want to
see alabama win because you knew that
georgia match-up was coming down the
road well i'll tell you what joel in all
honesty this is house money to me and i
i figure like if michigan's going to
reach the promised land which words i
never thought i would say into this
microphone uh truly i i
um they're gonna have to beat the best
anyway and and if they're gonna have to
go through the top two teams of the sec
with due respect to cincinnati then then
so be it but i i didn't get the whole
concept of you know they don't want to
rematch them and
being like so what so new year's eve um
folks will be just like you know what
i'm not interested in alabama and
georgia i saw that a month ago really i
mean like i i
i don't know about that um and and in
the same way what people will be less
interested on january 10th because we
saw it on december 4th i don't i don't
know i mean that that's to me is more
than just a regional game even though it
is technically a a
conference rematch
you know i mean it still would be a
month apart right the ratings would
suggest and i don't have them right in
front of me but it was not a very um
well uh watched game if you would say it
that way
when georgia and alabama played in the
national championship a few years ago
when tua came in off the benches of
freshmen and i think and and i think
that you know there are some me included
that think that if we do get georgia and
alabama i don't think that's great for
the sport
i don't think these rematches within
conferences you know without an expanded
playoff
are are good for the sport because it's
such a narrow window to get included
into the playoffs that this this purely
subjective measure of four best versus
four most deserving
i think has has hindered
uh the sports popularity to be quite
honest with you and it's made it more
regional and it's made
fan bases in other parts of the country
you know come up with theories and and
of bias and and such that
could be true or not true and so i think
that that if we can get away from that
it would be better rich i think that we
need to go to a 12 team playoff in
college football i think that we need to
have the six best champions across the
sport conference champions we need to
see them one through six the four best
champions uh have to win your conference
championship would get a bye and then
the next four best teams would would
host first round games and that's ways
that we can incentivize not only being
great but winning your conference
championship and giving you a distinct
advantage at the kickoff of this playoff
one of the things that you think about
is that we played this sec championship
game and it's basically just for like
their sec championship trophy because
georgia and alabama get to play on the
exact same footing no one got an
advantage over the other in this very
narrow playoff in this four team
subjective race that we have now in this
beauty pageant and i think that's what
what
it when we're raised
as as american sports fans to
to look at who's being incentive uh you
know where's the incentive lie in terms
of postseason and who's earning the
advantage in the postseason and then we
see what happens in college football i
think we all kind of sit there and pause
and think to ourselves well this isn't
right
joel klatt here uh on the rich eisen
show
so um do you think the heisman committee
got that right as well yeah i mean i
think that i i really
appreciate the fact that they looked at
their model and adjusted and and what
they adjusted on is that now they take
the four
um
top vote getters and bring them as
finalists every year rather than
sometimes we would have three and
sometimes we would have five and and
they did it based on how close the boat
was at least now there's this point of
demarcation where it's like listen if
i'm good enough to be one of the top
four vote getters in the heisman trophy
regardless of how how far back i am
because trust me i i guarantee you those
guys at 2 3 and 4 are going to be pretty
pretty far back from bryce young you
know i get to go be a heisman finalist i
get to honor uh my program and all those
things so i think that's that's a really
good change that the heisman has has
brought to pass over the last couple of
years um having said that yeah i think
that these were the four guys that i was
looking at will anderson probably was
close to being right there uh the
outside linebackers defensive end for
alabama
he's been phenomenal this year
but aiden hutchinson just played so
dominant in the biggest environments of
the year you look at his back end of the
season and what he was able to do in
particular in that ohio state game three
sacks against the best passing offense
in the country um i think that they got
it right guys i think that this guy is
is an absolute freak and that uh he
deserved to be in new york what about
top pick first one heard in in vegas you
know uh
now the eye in the sky has got all the
tape uh to save one game
um for for evaluators next year in the
nfl and some of these kids might not
play one more bowl game because they're
not in the college football playoffs so
um
what do you think is is hutchinson is
aiden hutchinson first overall how does
that suss out to you right now he's
definitely going to be in play now there
are guys i think kayvon thibodeau may be
more physically gifted than aiden
hutchinson but he doesn't come close to
playing as hard as hutchinson does on a
play-in and play-out basis rich it's
amazing how hard this guy plays on every
single snap runs at him runs away from
him pass play screenplays it doesn't
matter this dude never stops it's
relentless it's beautiful to watch he's
also very skilled and he has a plan he's
strong he's got all the things that you
probably sit there and roll your eyes at
for over the you know however long 20
years you've been doing it he's got the
speed to power and he can flip his hips
and yada yada yada you know what he does
he gets it done man he's a football
player jesse and and i think that he'll
absolutely be in play at that top pick
because of it which quarterback do you
think gets pushed to the top because
there's a need and so on and so forth
first blush right here in early december
joel i'm not sure i i would probably say
matt corral he's got to me the the most
physically gifted upside and and i think
he would be that guy
but i
i've got this sneaky like suspicion that
kenny pickett is going to be
the fastest riser up boards of the of
the draft season the the quarterback
from pitt he just reminds me too much of
the mac jones joe burrow
baker mayfield has played a lot of
football and then you put on his tape
and you're like man he gets it he please
he's accurate so i would say just like
watch out for kenny pickett do you think
the heisman uh committee can uh remake
the trophy for kenny if he wins it uh as
a fake slide instead of a stiff arm what
do you think do you think you can do
that that would be amazing and when you
when you actually throw you know it's
almost like a dead leg like fake slide
more power to you it's an amazing it's
an amazing move i i would have torn both
knees trying to do that
where do you stand though on the debate
that it shouldn't be allowed though what
do you think that he utilized that's
player safety rule to his advantage to
dupe the backs into thinking he's
sliding and then and then scored what do
you where do you stand on that one yeah
i mean
that's a that's a tough one because it
it shows
i guess it's so subjective i mean it
gets back to almost like the tuck rule
listen i think that if there's if
there's any it should be like the fair
catch
you know it's like the hand can barely
go up and they're like nope that's a
fair catch they just like err on the
side of fair catch
and we always say that like the ball
goes back to the spot where you start to
give yourself up well if you start to
give yourself up play should be dead
right if we're going to take the ball
back to that point then that's what
they're telling us anyways right is that
the play is dead at that moment that
when you start to give yourself up so if
there's any inclination that you're
going to give yourself up feet first i
think that the play should be dead
whether your knee hits the knee hits the
ground or not
uh that's how i think that we should
play this should be almost uh identical
to the fair catch joel klatt here on the
rich eisen show uh last one for you joel
i'm i i'm i'm sure you have an opinion
on all this about what's going on
with lincoln riley and brian kelly and
now uh cristobal going uh from oregon to
to miami but uh uh you know the latter
doesn't compare to the first two because
the first two happened
just as the season had ended right for
those teams and notre dame's season was
still very much alive for a national
championship and i had um i still i had
lincoln riley on yesterday and and asked
him if this december 15th signing date
is something he'd be willing to or or to
move and because that seems to be to to
be crunching all of these programs and
coaches to make decisions that are ugly
for kids and it's bad looks all around
and i'm just wondering why school
presidents and and those in management
and athletic departments don't have a
problem with it like that yeah let's
just keep signing these kids on december
15th and make it a big problem for
everybody
well
the problem with college football is
that there are too many academics
involved and not enough businessmen
okay like
because college football just lives in
theories
and then it takes
18 committees of 30 people to sit around
and debate something and then someone
decides that it's going to happen and
it's
the bureaucracy in in our sport is is
the worst part about it now that doesn't
answer your question but it gets that
kind of what the root issue is
we decided that we're going to do this
early signing day period which i don't
think benefits anybody in fact i think
it was born out of out of the coach's
anxiety through the holiday season and
bowl season about the impending
um
signing day in in february which is
where it was traditionally i think it
was like the first wednesday in february
is where it was traditionally at and it
should go back to that because not only
are we getting now because of the
structure of the sport these types of
emotional decisions which leave people
spurned and burned and you know it kind
of like sings shock waves through whole
programs like lincoln riley and brian
kelly
when it shouldn't be like it shouldn't
be that way and and there should be time
to make this decision and to move
forward so i i think that the recruiting
calendar should absolutely be looked at
but also you know
rich i think that we should adopt more
nfl style rules because they do it right
in terms of the league year and the
calendar and when you like when are
there tampering rules in effect and
whether they're not when can you talk to
guys and when can you not because
college football is the wild west and i
think that we need some of those guard
rails and they've been so
um you know they've pushed against those
guard rails so much in in part because
there's no overarching governing body we
don't have a commissioner that looks out
for the best part of the sport or the
best interest of the sport all we have
is special interest throughout the sport
whether it's conferences or programs or
coaches or players themselves and
everybody acts in their own best
interest that's the structure of our
sport well that's not going to be good
for it long term in particular with the
revenue that we're bringing in and what
we're doing from from
a media standpoint you know this this is
not healthy when you're talking about
guys getting paid a hundred million
dollars to leave 18 to 22 year olds in
the middle of the night that just is not
healthy so i think that we need to take
a look at all of those structure things
take a look at quote unquote a league
year what a calendar looks like when
when can you talk to people when can you
not when are there tampering charges
what are they not and move forward from
there i agree with you joel but the
question is is why don't others like joe
castiglione in oklahoma right he's as
good as they come in his position uh
he's got to go through a season
wondering is lincoln riley talking to
usc or somebody else um and and
and and he's you know of course he's not
fine with having his coach being poached
but
so do something about it right like
then get down and have all other
powerful athletic directors sit down and
make a move on this front and then if
you're a coach too like if you're
lincoln riley sure you and certainly if
you're if you're allowed to do it and
you can double your salary get a private
jet for your family and pay off
mortgages and things like that you're
all in on that sort of thing but you
don't want to sit there and answer
questions like like
he's been vilified for this and it's
like everybody would have done what he
did right so i i hate vilifying him just
because of the way it had to happen and
the timing in which it had to happen
i'll give you another point about this
early signing day that doesn't even have
to do with coaches you know the college
coaches how many times have you heard
them lament the fact that they've they
go through the bowl season or even the
playoff in a national championship and
then the coaches nick saban has said
like i got players that have to make a
decision about the nfl by next week and
we don't give them enough time to make a
decision about their nfl future because
when do they have to declare for the
draft right so that's the timing of all
that and yet they turn around and do
that to high school kids it's like oh
okay so now a high school kid has to
play a state championship game and turn
around and make a college decision that
quickly if he hasn't already already
committed it just doesn't make any sense
they talk out of both sides of their
mouth
and and the bureaucracy of college
football is is in in large part one of
the things that hinders it the most
joel i really appreciate the time always
just again great broadcast just great
and it really is just somebody who i as
you know i have an affinity for you and
i love working with you and getting the
opportunity to do that the fact that
your voice was actually associated with
football joy for me as opposed to the
last seven years has been a wonderful
turn of events i'll be very honest with
you joel it's going to make the draft
better let's hope
i look forward to that already but in
the meantime let's talk uh in short
order really appreciate your time all
right thank you
that's joe cloud everybody right back at
you at joel cloud i follow him on
twitter you should as well hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here